laura ingraham host the ingram angle of
course 10:00 Eastern here on Fox and she
is in London right now where it's about
1:00 in the morning she's been shirred
into those protests she took this
footage yourself watch her out of this
people will realize in America he's a
misogynist I don't think somebody who is
so much of a racist I think that Trump
is horrible I'm a really big threat to
the world waitress are up you know
unemployment is down doing historic low
and the economy is the envy of the world
I wouldn't entirely agree with Donna sad
people in a sad country one non sad
person no in London asourian joins us
live from there tonight Laura what's it
like well the protests were kind of a
letdown I mean I'm glad you started
Tucker with the Trump baby balloon
because that's about all they really
have they kind of had a Trump on the
toilet it's saying things like well you
know where's my cell phone and fake news
but that was just kind of funny but the
crowd the crowds weren't what they were
last year when the Trump was here where
it was just massive mean it was maybe I
mean I were guessing maybe 10,000 people
maybe 5,000 people but the strange thing
about it is that there was not really a
substantive criticism so much of Trump
and they just say no racist misogynist
he's a bad person kind of criticism it
was it's more like a it's like an
orthodoxy and ideology of the left to
reflexively be against him and after a
while it just became rather comical to
tell you the truth what now
Sadiq Khan who's the grotesque Mayor of
London has been in the kind of almost
direct spat with the president for the
last couple of days what is he been
saying well his whole point is that hit
Trump's values are London's values and
we talked to some actual you know Brits
today people who are born here grew up
here 25 miles outside of the city and I
said well the funny thing is about
London today it's like a lot of Brits
will say there's not as many
in London London is is a Mecca obviously
it's very culturally diverse a lot of
immigrants in London thriving city in
many ways bustling city but it's Sadiq
Khan kind of represents in many ways the
the more cosmopolitan thinking of US
cities so if you think about does LA
represent all of America well no of
course not la represents LA and that's
you know that's fine they don't like
Trump in LA or they don't like Trump in
in New York City or in Boston but you
get a little bit outside London and
things change people like well that's
the economy in the United States is
really strong and we kind of need more
independence and we don't want to answer
answer to Brussels but today and Sadiq
Khan represents us today it's it's all
you know Trump bad he's a bad person if
you support him you're a bad person to
that's essentially their argument so
three was three years ago almost exactly
three years ago that Britain's voted to
leave the European Union in the most
basic act of democracy and they're still
in has anybody noted to you that maybe
their democracy's fake is anybody upset
about that yeah I think a lot of people
are upset about it and that's why the
political turmoil now leading to Teresa
Mays leaving on Friday she nominally
remains in office until they
Conservative Party leader is selected to
replace her but unless this thing really
happens on October 31st and in brexit
happens we will see another general
election here in the UK and then who
knows we might have Nigel Faraj standing
for standing for the general election as
the brexit parties because the
Conservative Party at that point will be
over which is sad because a lot of us
grew up remembering Margaret Thatcher
and the and obviously the long history
of the Conservative Party long before
her in Britain but it's over for the
Conservative Party if they can't deliver
on this Tucker so what one last question
is who obviously our country was once a
colony of the country in which you're
standing right now so you can't help
when you visit there to think of like
maybe applicable lessons is there
anything that you've seen that it
informs the way you feel about our
country lessons that we should be like
yeah as much as we complain Tucker about
our you know representative democracy
and it's a we the will of the people is
too hard to to enact and and and we're
too distant from Washington well that's
true but compared to the parliamentary
system where its moves at a glacial pace
and it's really difficult to break
through as Faraj frankly did with this
brexit party be glad that you're in the
united states where every four years you
actually have a meaningful choice in
every two years you can choose your
representatives locally because they're
having a heck of a time here actually
enacting the will of the people on a
fundamental issue of independence and
sovereignty I don't think anybody even
understands the parliamentary system I I
certainly don't oh I'm off to off to
Normandy Tucker to Marty the breads do
you understand that and that's a it's
wonderful you're going they'll watch
thank you laura ingraham thanks sucker
in the UK